virgin hotels las vegas celebrating its
complete grand opening tonight
the property first opened its doors to
guests back in march
orco mana joins us live from its brand
new beach club
with more on tonight's star studded
event orca
brian this is a day virgin hotels las
vegas has been waiting for
for everything on property is finally
open that includes the ilia beach club
here behind me
which is brand new it boasts this
beautiful pool and cabana area
all inspired by mykonos greece and to
celebrate all the excitement
we've got some big names here tonight so
richard branson the founder of virgin
group kicking things off with a
champagne toast
and splash with some resort officials
and the nevada governor steve sisilak
all highlighting the return
of las vegas this is all part of
celebrating the full opening of virgin
hotels las vegas which means all venues
inside the resort are now complete
this also kicks off what the property is
calling unstoppable weekend there are
big name artists performing later
tonight
including singer christina aguilera
chart topper flo ryda
and iconic dj mix master mike you'll
remember virgin hotels las vegas which
was formerly the hard rock
first opened in march and now look
there's a brand new day club and the
party is just beginning
unstoppable weekend continues now
through sunday
reporting live tonight here at virgin
hotels las vegas
orca mana 8 news now